[Music]
let us face
without panic the reality of our times
the fact that atom bombs may someday be
dropped on our cities
and let us prepare for survival by
understanding the weapon that threatens
us
[Music]
an atom bomb destroys or injures in
three ways
by blast heat and radioactivity
the blast of an atom bomb is its most
important destructive agent
in japan whole buildings were flattened
by its force
however many buildings of sturdy
construction even though close to the
explosion
remains standing
the principal dangers of blast are
flying glass and debris
the fires it may start and the danger of
being crushed in collapsing buildings
the atom bomb destroys by heat people
caught in the open as far as two miles
away suffered flash burns
yet protection could have been easily
achieved
here a bridge post and rail shielded the
surface behind it
any solid material afforded similar
protection
the third weapon of the bomb is
radioactivity thrown off at the instant
of explosion
however the majority of people exposed
to radiation recovered completely
including a large percentage of those
who suffered serious radiation sickness
today they lead normal lives they bear
children
their children are normal these then
are the weapons of the atom bomb that we
must protect against
blast heat and radioactivity our cities
are prime targets for atomic attack
but mass evacuation would be disastrous
an enemy would like nothing better than
to have us leave our cities empty and
unproductive
if an emergency should come our
factories will be battle stations
production must go on if we are to win
our offices and homes will also be posts
of duty
not to be deserted
with the knowledge of the first atomic
explosions to guide us
our chances for survival will be far
better than those of the people of
hiroshima and nagasaki
if we act on our knowledge and are
prepared
the first job is to look over your own
home for shelter possibilities
if you live in a private home that is
well built the cellar is the safest
place to be
the lower you get the more barriers
there are likely to be against blast
heat and radioactivity select the
basement wall nearest the probable
target
area of your city if the house is blown
over
it will most likely fall away from this
wall
if you have a workbench or strong table
big enough to get under
move it into your shelter area near a
wall or strong supporting column
if the time comes when you actually have
to take shelter lie under the table
if you live in a home that has no
basement choose a shelter area without
windows
on the ground floor an interior hallway
is probably best
in time of emergency the shelter area
should be cleared of mirrors and other
objects that might cause injury
[Music]
if you lived in an apartment house rules
for taking shelter will be posted in
your building
learn them also learn the location of
public shelters in areas where you work
or frequently visit
there are many things you can begin
doing right now
fireproof housekeeping is one so clean
up that attic
keep waste in covered containers
don't let trash pile up in the yard set
aside a small supply of canned goods
they're safe from radioactivity
have a good flashlight on hand electric
lights may go out
keep a first aid kit and learn how to
stop bleeding
make a habit of keeping a bottle of
fresh water handy
a radio will be important for receiving
vital instruction
[Music]
finally prepare the shelter area and
collect all necessary shelter equipment
in case of an actual raid or test drill
the alert
will be a warbling siren blast lasting
three minutes
[Applause]
once you hear this act fast
pull down the shades or blinds and close
the drapes against flying glass
turn off the burners of your gas or
electric stove
[Music]
disconnect any heating elements such as
electric iron hot plates or bathroom
heaters
close all outside doors but leave them
unlocked
turn off the gas or oil burners
taking shelter may be a race against
time even when you have some advanced
warning
but possibly there may be no time an
attack could come without warning
the sky would suddenly light up if a
doorway is right at hand use it
if the nearest shelter is more than a
couple of steps away fall to the ground
immediately
flying glass and debris are immediate
dangers so stay where you are
until you're sure it's safe to move
[Music]
if you are at home when a surprise
attack occurs fall beneath the table
if it is very near or drop to the floor
with your back to the window
[Music]
the immediate danger is over in about a
minute unless the explosion occurred
near the ground or water
[Music]
in this case radioactive materials are
trapped in the particles of dirt or
water thrown up by the explosion
when these particles fall back to earth
they may be dangerous
so get indoors immediately after a
ground level explosion
cover broken windows against radioactive
dust with blankets or cardboard
[Music]
civil defense radiological teams
equipped with radiation survey meters
will check on contamination in any
bombed area
stay under cover until you hear
officially that it is safe outside
if you have been exposed to radioactive
dust wash the
exposed areas pay particular attention
to your hair
get all the dirt from under your
fingernails
if the people of hiroshima and nagasaki
had known what we know about civil
defense
thousands of lives would have been saved
yes
the knowledge is ours and preparation
can mean survival for you
so act now someday your life may depend
on it
you